if you were Gotham City's only hope to
fight off an ancient Creature From
Another reality what would you do Bruce
Wayne has been traveling the world for
20 years but now he must return to
Gotham to right the wrongs of the past
I'm here to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to beat the
cult of ghoul in Batman the Doom that
came to Gotham the world's greatest
detective is about to realize that not
all Mysteries can be solved with logic
and sometimes the truth really is
Stranger Than Fiction somewhere deep in
Antarctica Explorer Bruce Wayne and his
young assistant Dick Grayson and Sanjay
come across an abandoned research vessel
belonging to the missing Professor
Oswald cobblepot the Frozen corpses of
the crew litter the deck and the
surrounding ice but according to the
ship's manifest two bodies are missing a
man named grendon and Professor
cobblepot himself Sanjay points out that
it would be impossible for anyone to
survive in this Frozen Wasteland but
Bruce insists that they keep looking and
sets out on cobblepot's trail leaving
the boys with the ship searching for
evidence Grace and finds the professor's
Journal buried in the snow in sight he
reads that the men of the Expedition
slowly lost their minds over the course
of several days and cobblepot believed
that he could hear an unknown creature
calling out to him from beneath the ice
Bruce trudges through the snow until he
spots the professor in the distance
covered in a blue rash and severely
underdressed for the weather and Bruce
chases after him but the Cliff's side
suddenly gives out sending him tumbling
down into the Ravine below looking up
Bruce realizes that he's landed right in
front of a giant ice cave Bruce lights a
torch and heads inside and in there he
finds a strange man chipping away at a
massive wall of ice at first Bruce
thinks that it's the professor but the
man tells him that cobblepot is gone
Bruce says that he must be granted and
the man responds that he was once but
explained that his new master has called
him to a greater purpose looking up at
the ice Bruce sees an enormous creature
trapped inside and it peers back at him
with all three alien looking eyes
causing him to fall over in pain grendon
reveals that he cut out his own eyes to
serve his new master a creature who is
later identified as yib nogiroth the
sleeping child of some strange outer God
Bruce orders grendon to surrender but
the man says that he's not finished yet
and suddenly a group of deformed
Penguins leap out from above and attack
him Bruce kicks one across the cave and
takes another two down with a spin move
but no matter how much damage he causes
these creatures they keep getting back
up while Bruce is distracted with the
Monstrous Birds grendin grabs his
pickaxe and rushes back to the ice wall
hacking away at it until he's able to
crack its surface he raises his hands
towards the Frozen creature and several
in arms tentacles descend down towards
him and swallows one of them surrounded
by the mutated Penguins Roost draws a
flare gun and fires it into the air the
bright light causes the creatures to
retreat and suddenly grendon rushes him
with his pickaxe but Bruce drops it with
a straight punch to the face back to
their ship Bruce's third assistant Kylie
Kane receives a call on the radio from
her boss and he tells her to get their
entire stash of explosives ready they
line the mountain of the cave with
several bundles of dynamite and Bruce
sets off the explosion trapping the
enormous creature inside Grayson
questions if they made the right
decision saying that the creature could
have been valuable to science but Bruce
says that it was much too dangerous and
that whatever it was it needed to stay
buried the group takes grunden and
Boards their ship signing off for Gotham
as cobblepot and his demented Penguins
watch from the Cliffside on board the
boat Bruce's Butler Alfred arrives with
some lunch and notices a rancid smell
coming from somewhere in the room kindly
explained that the stent is coming from
grendon who started to decompose when
they warmed him up Grayson says that the
tissue samples from the man indicated
that he's actually dead but somehow he's
still very much alive and so they've
stored him in the meat freezer until
they can come up with a better solution
Alfred finds Bruce sitting in his office
Reading from cobblepot's journal and
Bruce tells him that the book points to
the existence of an ancient cult which
aims to destroy Gotham he says that
after 20 years away they must return to
the city and presses a secret button
under his Batman desk reveal feeling his
batsuit hidden behind the bookshelf as
this ship arrives at the Port Bruce has
a flashback to the night that his
parents were murdered he remembers how
his mother and father took him for a
walk through the park when suddenly they
were attacked by a Madman wielding a
dagger the man tackled his father to the
ground and when his mother rushed to
help he knocked her away causing her to
die from the fall The Psychotic attacker
stabbed his father in the chest laughing
maniacally and Bruce ran for his life to
the top of a nearby Clock Tower in the
darkness above him he saw the shape of a
many-eyed octopus-like creature and a
horde of bats surrounded him from the
Shadows back on the boat Grayson asks
Bruce what they're going to do with
grendon he tells them they're going to
leave him on the ship the three of them
draw straws to see who will babysit the
zombie and unfortunately Sanjay pulls
the shortest one and reluctantly stays
behind while the others get to do the
fun part and go into the city the four
of them arrive at Wayne Manor and are
greeted by Bruce's business manager he
assures Bruce that the company is going
strong and tells him that he set up the
cellar according to his specifications
inside Alfred finds a letter from from
Bruce's good old friend Oliver Queen
inviting them over for dinner and drinks
and suddenly Kylie screams and they rush
over to see what's wrong in the study
they find a mangled corpse sitting in a
chair the body is covered in claw marks
and Bruce realizes from the bruising on
its neck that would ever killed the man
also had thumbs he leans in for a closer
look and has a hallucination of the body
telling him that its name is langstrom
causing him to back away in fear Grayson
asks if they should contact the police
but Bruce tells him because they're
superheroes they can handle it later
that night Bruce gets ready to visit his
friend Oliver Queen when he notices a
strange Man Standing Outside the man
tells him that his name is blood and in
the mirror Bruce sees the man's
reflection briefly transformed into a
fiery demon he explains that Bruce's
return to Gotham has set a terrible fate
into motion but although he knows the
truth he can only give him three hints
about what's going to happen first Bruce
must seek out two Spirits one wrapped in
bats and the other in Flames second
Bruce must die in order to become his
true self and third Gotham must bear
turned to the ground before it can be
saved Bruce tells the man that he
doesn't believe in ghost stories and
tries to escort him out but blood fights
back and Bruce slams him down onto the
desk and suddenly the man bursts into
flames and knocks Bruce across the room
revealing his true identity etragon the
demon the monster tells Bruce that he's
not his enemy before leaping through the
window into the night at Oliver's
Mansion the four of them sit around the
table sharing stories when a surprise
guest arrives Bruce's good friend and
future mayor of Gotham Harvey Dent Bruce
asks Harvey If the name langstra means
anything to him and he explains that the
man was a professor at the local
University who had an unhealthy
obsession with bats Harvey goes home for
some sleep and Bruce asks Oliver if they
can spend the night at his place to
which he happily agrees leaving the kids
to watch out for Oliver Bruce Dawn's bat
suit and heads out into the night okay I
know I know Batman is the world's
greatest detective but this time it
looks like he might be in a little bit
over his cow this superhero might not
believe in the Supernatural but to quote
Captain Barbosa you better start
believing in Ghost Stories Mr Batman
you're in one look the first very
obvious sign that something Beyond
logical explanation is going down is the
appearance of our friend Oswald
cobblepot in his birthday suit looking
like a rejected member of the Blue Man
Group but given the fact that they're in
the heart of Antarctica and he's been
missing for several weeks and kabapod
not being turned into a Kabul popsicle
raises some serious questions about
what's really happening down here at the
main United States research station in
Antarctica the average annual
temperature is a less than comfortable
zero degrees Fahrenheit no person could
survive more than a few hours out there
tops even if they were addressed
properly for the weather and while
cobblepot might have had the added
benefit of a Burly frame going for him
but even with his extra layers of
blubber long-term survival and the
Antarctic without shelter or supplies
would be impossible upon immediately
seeing him Bruce's bad senses should
have started tingling warning him that
whatever he was about to face might be
outside the scope of his usual logic
driven investigations and when Bruce
found a zombified grended inside the
cave Ben thing to do would have been to
attack right now while he still has the
element of surprise as soon as the guy
started ranting about being Charles and
by the creature as its Messenger to the
world I would have given him a quick
knee to the back of the head and figured
out what the message was later the
creature under the ice is later revealed
to be a child of the outer gods and for
a context the outer gods or a group of
cosmic entities that exist outside of
our understanding of reality and they
exert their influence on our world
through their Cults often seeking to
corrupt or completely destroy our
universe for their own evil intentions
so he's going to need more than his
sharp wits and martial arts to get this
job done Bruce decides to destroy the
cave and bury the creature under the ice
which is probably best course of actions
but I don't like the fact that it could
still be alive down there but signing
off the explosions directly where it was
trapped in an attempt to confirm the
kill could have accidentally set it free
and Bruce might not understand exactly
what the creature was yet but he's right
to say that it was much too dangerous to
try to study it and speaking of things
being left behind Bruce really should
have gone after cobblepot one more time
before heading home at after making sure
that grendon was Secure I would have
taken Grayson with me and headed back to
the area around the cave odds are good
that cobblepot might be wandering around
because he would think the coast is
clear and look even if we didn't catch
him there we might be able to capture
one of his straggling pet zombie
penguins and use it to lure him into a
trap one lonely guy with a Danny DeVito
build stuck in the most extremely
isolated place on the planet might not
seem like a major threat to society but
based on his journal and what Bruce saw
in the cave there's definitely still
potential for cobblepot to cause some
major Cobble troubles if left to his own
devices if he were to somehow be able to
float his blubberists way back to the
mainland who knows what kind of chaos he
might spread plus if Bruce had been able
to capture him they could have grilled
him for more information that would have
helped them understand what they're
facing and on top of that keeping
grendon alive was a major slip up and is
likely going to cause them trouble down
the road he's obviously going to be a
threat if he manages to escape and
personally I would have just let the guy
melt the dead man has obviously lost his
mind and is still only alive because
he's been zombified by the creature so
by letting him melt in into a collective
pile of goop is arguably the most Humane
and safe thing to do what does Bruce do
no he doesn't do that he decides to
bring the crepe directly to Gotham and
then leave him alone with an unarmed
teenager and for Bruce being a tactical
genius this plan seems a little batty to
me at Wayne Manor Bruce finds the body
of a man who was killed by a human
animal hybrid of some kind instead of
just dumping the body into the bad cave
and moving on with their lives I would
have had Grace and help me perform an
on-the-spot autopsy to see if we could
learn a little bit more about who the
man was what killed him and how we could
fight it if it comes after us now if
you're a multi-billionaire wealthy
Explorer returning from home for the
first time in 20 years only to find a
mangled corpse in your house and a few
hours later a mysterious Man shows up at
your front door unannounced are you
really going to let him in just for a
casual conversation I would have told
Alfred to send the creepo packing and
then send Grayson to follow him to find
out who the guy was and what he wanted
and the thing is it turns out that the
visitor isn't a guy at all but a
mysterious rhyming demon and he's there
with a warning for Bruce first he tells
Bruce that he must seek out his Spirit
wrapped in bats and another one in
flames and secondly he says that Bruce
must die and become his true self in
order to win now I'm not exactly sure
how that's going to play out but if
we're taking what he says literally I do
have a plan in the game Arc of Origins
Bruce is forced to break his no killing
rule to defeat his enemy and he manages
to revive them again by using a pair of
shock gloves so if Bruce thinks that
he'll have to die in order to Prevail
against whatever he's fighting then I
would have had Grace and wake me up a
handy bad defibrillator so that way I
could hopefully use this to loophole my
way to an advantage that way if Bruce
really did have to technically die one
of the kids could have revived him and
finally the demon says that Gotham will
have to burn before it can be saved
again we're taking this literally since
we've still got grendon around I would
have sent Grayson back to the ship to
find some way to harness his ice powers
into a tool that I could use to put out
the Flames once the fire started since
he's able to create a suit to keep the
man alive I'm sure he could have come up
with some way to use his control of the
cold to our advantage also I'd have him
whip up some ice grenades or maybe some
freezing gauntlets in case I have
another run-in with this flaming demon
and also Grayson will still be close by
in case I need a backup and he could
also help Sanjay if things went wrong on
the boat and now we're at Oliver's house
Bruce discovers that the body he's found
in his study belonged to the biologist
Kirk langstrump a man who was obsessed
with bats so there you go that's your
spirit wrapped in bats right there it's
a good lead no so I'd want to find out
more about the man in his research to
see if I could learn anything that would
help me understand the truth about
what's going on and one final thought
before we join back with our Caped
Crusader Oliver's excessive drinking and
strange body language including the
clutching at his necklace indicates that
he's got something to hide my instincts
tells me he knows something about what's
going on so I would have Kylie look
around his place while he's in a drunken
stupor to see what she can find out with
night falling it's time for Bruce to
suit up and we'll have to see what he
discovers next to unravel more of this
Mr Bruce now Batman leaps from rooftop
to Rooftop and swings through the
streets with his grapple gun until he
arrives at the window of langstrump's
office inside he sees a group of crooked
cops pilfering the place for any
valuables Batman lands on the window and
they open a fire but he tackles the
first guy and takes out the other with a
batarang and leaps onto the third
knocking him to the ground and taking
them all out at once with battlelicious
move surging around the office he finds
a strange signal on the floor and checks
it out with a UV light and there he
notices a large clawed footprint leading
to the door and a floorboard where it
looks like something is hidden pulling
up the boards he finds langstrump's
journal and escapes just as Commissioner
Gordon walks in Batman goes to a nearby
rooftop and opens the journal according
to langstrom his bats warned him of a
creature from another reality that wants
to consume the world a centuries-old
cult wishes to summon the creature but
can only do so if they acquire a special
book The Testament of ghoul Batman
remembers reading about the book in
cobblepot's journal and decides to head
to the university to see what he can
find from a telephone pole across the
street Batman calls the university
office and asks the man on the other end
about the Testament the man says that
he's never heard of it but Batman
watches through the window as he
immediately grabs the book from a hidden
compartment suddenly a mysterious woman
enters the room and Batman recognizes
her as Talia al Ghul the daughter of the
cult's founder he begs her not to kill
him but she opens a bottle and a little
red lizard climbs out and jumps into his
ear Talia picks up the book but Batman
crashes through the window cutting off
her exit and suddenly the man bursts
into flames morphing into a huge Red
Demon and throwing Batman around the
room with ease realizing that it's a
fight that he can't win Batman throws a
vial of acid onto the floor and jumps
down through the hole just as the roof
above them caves in for a moment it
looks like he got away but the demon
crashes through the ceiling right in
front of Batman and the fight's not over
yet and just then the other demon bursts
through the window and tells Batman to
grab after Talia while he holds off the
Demonic librarian Batman confronts
Natalya in the streets below but she
throws a handful of strange dust in his
face and a giant creature called Killer
Croc ambushes him from behind he swings
around a statue and kicks the monster
off of the bridge but Talia Escapes in
the confusion they square up on a
railroaded track but a train comes
hurtling out of the tunnel and Batman
grapples away just in time his Croc
bounces off of the engine both of them
injured but still alive the monster goes
to see Talia of the sewers and she
orders him to go to the harbor and
retrieve grendon from the boat okay a
whole lot is happening right now things
just went from bad to worse and now
there's a big green monster loose in the
sewers great Batman goes to the
university and tries to get the book
before the bad guys can't but ends up
leading Talia right to it to distract
him Talia unleashes a creature and now
I've never heard of this monster so I
did some research and found out and they
seem to have a weakness to incredibly
bright lights so after barely surviving
the first fight I would have prepared
myself with some flashbang grenades in
case I came up against this creature
again that way I could have easily taken
this thing out and focused my attention
on getting that book back Batman hardly
has time to collect his thoughts before
he's ambushed by this universe's version
of Killer Croc and while he's distracted
Talia manages to escape with the book
which is exactly what we didn't want to
happen trying to be the croc in a fist
fight is pointless and he's not even the
main threat so I would have tried my
best to dodge him while looking for an
opportunity to destroy the book instead
now I know it's not going to be easy but
Batman didn't need to actually defeat
either one of them the most important
thing was the book don't Let the book
get into the wrong hands if Batman could
have gone away from Croc for just a
second he could have snatched the book
from Talia and tossed it Into The
Inferno of the birding Library
destroying the Testament and taking away
the cult's only hope at succeeding at
their plan his priorities were in the
wrong place when he should have just
focused on getting the book or
destroying it at any costs the next
morning at Wayne Manor Alfred opened the
window and finds an injured Batman
outside he limps in and heads to the
Batcave to study the substance that the
monster left on his suit and prepares
himself for the next fight meanwhile at
the harbor the police noticed that
Bruce's boat is surrounded by icebergs
even though it's the middle of June
Oliver and the kids show up and he
distracts the cops while Grayson heads
out to the ship and he sneaks Around The
Horde with his rifle and finds Sanjay
frozen stiff grendon laughs at him from
the freezer and suddenly Croc burst
through the floor and kills him the
police finally get to the ship at all
they find are Sanjay and Grayson's
bodies with no sign of grendon or Croc
Kylie bursts into tears when she sees
the bodies of her friends and Oliver
Comforts her promising to avenge them
meanwhile in a cave somewhere deep under
Gotham Talia places an urn in the center
of a seagull her demon arrives showing
her that is captured at Trigon he steps
into the seagull igniting it in Flames
as he descends to his home down to the
depths of Hell the urn bursts into a
green Whirlwind forming into the shape
of a giant man
talia's father and the leader of the
cult searching for answers Bruce flipped
through a book about the dark arts until
he comes across the page on Al ghoul's
cult it explains that his greatest
desire was to serve his master an outer
God called log sotha and to bring him to
our reality Bruce notices an ancient
form of writing known as aklow on the
page and quickly deduces that the cult's
ritual site is somewhere in the tunnels
beneath the city Bruce puts on the cowl
and heads down into the sewers to see
what he can find and inside he comes
across the tunnel illuminated by candles
and he hears strange chanting at the
other end Roz and Talia stand in the
center of the room praying to their
Master but Batman throws a batarang and
extinguishes all of the candles and then
Killer Croc lunges from the shadows and
Batman throws two glass jars full of
chlorine concentrate at him melting him
into a puddle of green goo Talia blows
more dust in his face but Batman blocks
it with his cape and quickly slips on a
gas mask she leaps at him through the
dust shattering the mask with a kick but
Batman counters her blows disarming her
and putting her in a Chokehold and
grabbing the bottle containing etrigan
he orders Roz to stand down but Talia
breaks free as the floor caves in and
Batman falls into a pool of green water
deep below and sometimes later he climbs
out of the sewer into the streets of the
city their outfit arrives to pick him up
as he collapses from exhaustion okay so
much for our boy wonders with Sanjay on
ice and Grayson becoming crack food it's
now all up to Kylie Oliver and Bruce to
save the day but after considering his
fight with Talia and her minions the bat
is not doing exactly a whole lot better
himself after learning about the cult
and its intentions Batman should have
known right away that Granton was
somehow connected I would have gone
straight back to the ship hopefully
getting there in time to save Sanjay's
life and there set up a trap for Croc
when he showed up they could have made
it look like nobody was on board and
could have gotten the jump on the
creature while he was distracted then
they could have just used some heavy
chains to restrain him and remove a
major threat from the fight I'd much
rather battle krag on my own terms
instead of fighting down in the sewers
where he has the upper hand I would have
used grendon as bait and have taken the
opportunity to strike when he wasn't
expecting it and by reading through a
book on the dark arts Bruce is now able
to figure out the location of the cult's
secret Temple and now that he knows the
Temple's coordinates I would have used
his Bruce's enormous wealth to hire a
construction team for a project right
above it after they closed down the area
I would have told them to take the rest
of the day off gave them their pay and
send them on their way that way I know
that there's absolutely no innocent
people nearby then I would have headed
down into the source for the final
showdown and set up some Dynamite along
the way giving Alfred and Kylie the
orders to set it off if anything goes
wrong now Bruce wisely decides to study
the Slime that Croc left on him to see
if he could figure out any weakness
before their next encounter but when the
battle kicks off Bruce simply hits Croc
with some chlorine concentrate a
corrosive agent that quickly turns Croc
into a puddle of slime but given his
strength and knowledge of talia's plan I
might have taken a different approach
and tried to keep Croc alive if Batman
could have subdued Kroc with
tranquilizers or electric shock he might
have been able to use him to learn more
about the cult or even turn him to their
side and have a powerful Ally in the
future worst case scenario he would have
made a great meet Shield if my fight
with Talia and Roz wasn't going well and
instead of using the chlorine on Croc
Batman could have used it to destroy oh
I don't know the book take away the most
essential part of the cult's plan he had
an open shot when he first snuck into
the temple and just one well-placed
Arrow could have melted that Testament
stabbing Roz and Talia in their tracks
and Roz was able to finish his
incantation while Batman was distracted
which caused the floor to collapse when
it looks like Batman had the upper hand
look if I was Batman and I'm falling I
would have tried to fire the grapple gun
up there and pull myself back up that
way they wouldn't have been able to
escape so easily back in their Lair
Talia stabbed grended in the chest and a
tiny ball of tentacles falls out of his
mouth as he melts into a puddle of blue
slime the ball descends Into The Grandin
juice and rises in the shape of a
red-headed woman Talia sends this
version of poison ivy after their next
Target Harvey Dent and he takes her hand
and she marks him with some substance on
her thumb before walking away meanwhile
at Oliver's Kylie notices him sneaking
into a room and locking the door behind
him she breaks in with a lockpick and
sees all of her kneeling in front of an
altar wearing a suit of armor and arming
himself with sacred Arrow stained with
the blood of Saint Sebastian he explains
to her that his father was over 300
years old having made a pact with the
devil for eternal life eventually he was
driven insane and ended up murdering
Bruce's parents which then awoke an
ancient evil that will one day destroy
Gotham Oliver says that it's up to him
to make things right and tells Kylie to
go before the creature comes after him
we're now back at the bat cave bearman
is speaking to langstrom's body
realizing that he's the spirit wrapped
in bats that the good Demon mentioned
before about Kylie comes back to check
on and warns him that something is wrong
with Oliver kneeling in front of the
altar Oliver hears footsteps approaching
from behind and hits poison ivy with a
no look throwing knife straight to the
Dome he raises the bow but the woman
pulls the knife out of her head and
transforms into a huge demonic creature
attacking him with long roots like arms
Oliver Dodges around the chapel firing
Arrow after Arrow into the creature but
she destroys his bow and he lunges at
her with a battle ax but the monster
overpowers him impaling him with a root
but at the last moment he pulls out a
holy hand grenade and turns her into
firewood Batman and Kylie arrive on the
scene and find Oliver Gravely injured
but the creature destroyed Oliver and
Bruce share a heartfelt moment before he
dies and he clears Oliver of the guilt
for his father's crimes Bruce takes his
Dagger of the quiver of sacred arrows
and goes to finish the fight leaving
Oliver's Body behind Okay so now it
turns out that Batman wasn't the only
Dark Knight in town with Oliver down
he's lost another powerful Ally but he's
now got some really sweet tools that he
can use in his next fight Oliver
traveled the world to prepare himself
for battle becoming an expert at
fighting all kinds of beasts he didn't
really have to do that let me explain
he's got his throwing knives and arrows
but he can keep them honestly what he
really needed was a big old chainsaw
seriously one quick trip to Home Depot I
would have had all that I needed to turn
this poison ivy into Twigs Oliver hits
her with almost everything he's got
ultimately resorting to blowing up ivy
with a holy hand grenade now while I
admit sure yes it got the job done but I
would have used the Arrows with the
blood of Saint Sebastian on them that he
specifically pointed out to Kylie just
moments before the fight one well placed
shot with one of those would have
definitely put this demon down and since
their arrows he could have just
retrieved them from Ivy's body after the
fight was over Batman could have used
his help in the coming battles against
Talia and Roz so it sucks that he chose
to sacrifice himself just to take out
their least threatening minion he may
have been too late to save his friend
but now Batman's arm with some certified
demon slaying tools so now it's time to
send these cultish freaks back to the
pit from whence they came and do it
before the entire city is destroyed
meanwhile Harvey sits alone in his house
for the disgusting purple rash taking
over the entire left side of his body
Talia enters the room behind him and he
begs her to put him out of his misery
but she says that he still has a job to
do Bruce goes to visit the graves of
Grayson and Sanjay and Kylie tries to
convince him to give up before it's too
late but he says that he can't leave
Gotham Commissioner Gordon shows up and
tells Bruce that his medium daughter
Barbara says that his Spirit needs to
speak with him and Bruce agrees to visit
her that night saying that it's finally
time to figure out who this Spirit
wrapped in Flames is Bruce goes to the
bat cave and puts on his suit grabbing
the arrow stagger and bottle containing
the good Demon Alfred tries to stop it
but Bruce says that he has to go and he
reluctantly flips a switch availing the
Batmobile Bruce tells Kylie that she's
in charge of the bat cave and now says
goodbye to Alfred before climbing into
the Batmobile and speeding off to Arkham
Asylum in inside Batman goes to
Barbara's cell and he asks her to speak
to the spirit wrapped in Flames she asks
him if he's sure that he wants this but
he says that he doesn't have a choice
and she calls out to the spirit from
Beyond the Grave Bruce opens his eyes
and sees his father Thomas sitting in a
chair in front of him he explains to
Bruce that he was one of the original
settlers of Gotham but his people were
struggling to survive they discovered
the temple deep below their land and
Oswald cobblepot Henry Queen Bartley
langstrom and himself performs dark
rituals there in exchange for the
colony's Prosperity the four of them
were given eternal life and after a
while they all but forgot about the vile
things that they'd done until one day
they realized that they accidentally
attracted logs sotha to their reality
Bartley langstrump took his own life
cobblepot fled to Antarctica and Henry
killed Thomas and his wife during a
psychotic episode and Thomas tells Bruce
that there's still a chance to stop the
creature before it destroys the world
but he must embrace the madness and
speak to the bats to find out how Batman
Returns to langstrom's office and kneels
in the center of the sigil drinking the
concoction that allowed the doctor to
communicate with the bats repeats an
incantation and suddenly the sickle
glows blue and he's surrounded by a
horde of talking bats they tell him that
he's now one of them and to return to
the temple below the city so that he can
stop logs so far in the temple Batman
finds Harvey fused to the wall with a
strange purple portal glowing behind him
he tells Harvey that he'll see him again
soon and steps through the portal into
the Cave's Beyond suddenly a hand bursts
through the ground and Batman slices it
off with a batarang mutated versions of
Oliver Sanjay and Grayson rise to the
surface and Batman asks them to forgive
him he throws three batarangs into the
mutant Grayson before stabbing Oliver
and Sanjay in their heads as well but
the creatures are all unharmed dodging
their attacks he draws his bow and fires
one of the Sacred arrows into Sanjay's
chest causing him to explode in a burst
of blue light he prepares to fire at
Oliver but Grayson breaks his bow and
Batman leaps towards him plunging an
arrow into his chest finally Batman
rushes Oliver and stabs him in the head
with a third arrow and as he dies he
thanks Batman and tells him to finish
the fight before being engulfed by the
blue flame okay it looks like Bruce
wasn't the only one fighting his demons
it turned out that the spirit wrapped in
Flames was his own father who made a
really stupid pact with the outer Gods
to save his dying settlement hundreds of
years before instead of making a pact
with a creature beyond my understanding
I would have tried to just get good at
bombing or hunting so I wouldn't starve
desperate times call for desperate
measures I guess in the caves beneath
Gotham Batman finds a mutated Harvick
hutalia and Roz have used to create a
doorway for their tentacle to master I'm
not exactly sure how nobody in the city
noticed that their newly elected mayor
turning into a giant purple blob I know
that Batman has a no killing rule but
I'm curious what would have happened if
he just decided to put Harvey out of his
misery perhaps the Gateway would have
just shut trapping Talia and Roz in
their alternate reality although I'm
sure that they wouldn't have left Harvey
unguarded if that was the case inside
the cape Batman has to take out the
mutated zombie versions of his three
dead friends before he's even able to
get back to the real battle and at first
it looks like the creatures can't be
harmed but the Holy Arrow seemed to do
the trick although after this battle
he's only got one left and two more
demons that still need slang if he had
created some ice grenades like I
mentioned before he could have countered
their regenerative abilities by freezing
them and breaking them apart piece by
piece defeating him that way and saving
the arrows for the real and actually
important fight with all of their
minions down the only obstacles
remaining are Talia and Roz but we can't
forget that according to the good Demon
Bruce needs to die in order to
ultimately Prevail but speaking of our
friendly demon Bruce still has the guy
in a jar so maybe now is a good time to
set him free this way he could help me
out in the last fight because hey it's
time for the final showdown and we have
to see if bats can stop their plot
before log Sota devours Gotham and
eventually the world Batman walks
further into the cave and comes across a
large chamber bathed in purple light Roz
stands at an altar in the center
repeating an incantation as The
Testament dissolves in the flesh and
blue circles appear on the floor around
if Batman approaches them and Talia
fires a green bolt of lightning at him
before using her magic to damage the
bridge they leap into the air and she
kicks him down destroying more and more
of the bridge with each of her heavy
blows Batman blocks her attacks and
kicks her in the face and leaps to the
platform as the bridge crumbles but she
jumps in front of him cutting off his
path Talia reaches down and grabs Bruce
by the neck holding him up before
tossing him into the pit but he fires
his grapple gun right through his
shoulder pulling himself up and driving
the last sacred Arrow straight into her
chest Batman confronts Ross but he pins
him to the ground with his green magic
and raises his hand to the seal opening
the door for his God just that Batman
lunges at him from behind cutting his
arm clean off with the sacrificial
dagger and suddenly Roz grows a mass of
tentacles from where his arm used to be
and knocks Batman back across the
platform he shouts that he's a child of
the outer gods and reveals his final
form a giant purple squid demon Roz
holds Batman up with one of his long
arms electrocuting him with his green
lightning as the sky over Gotham turns
blood red Batman closes his eyes and Roz
slams him to the ground but a giant
clawed hand bursts from the rubble
revealing that Batman himself has
transformed into a demonic bad creature
he tears off Roz's tentacle flying
around the cave and ripping him apart
piece by piece before pinning him to the
ground and sinking his teeth into his
neck green light bursts from his many
eyes as Roz explodes and unfortunately
logs sotha reaches through the portal
into their reality at the last moment
Batman remembers the jar containing his
friend demon and shatters it on the
ground the demon tells Batman that his
job is done and he flies out of the cave
as the demon explodes and Flames
destroying the cape system antiog sotha
and killing Harvey in the process which
now leads Kylie now is the last survivor
okay this has got to be the weirdest
version of Batman I've ever seen look it
looks like the city is saved but Bruce
Harvey and his friendly demon all have
to make the ultimate sacrifice to do it
and during their fight Batman manages to
take Talia down with the last of
Oliver's sacred arrows and since he only
had one Arrow left I would have tried to
fire the gravel straight into Roz
instead of the rocks and now with Talia
finally laid to rest Batman and Ross
screw off for their final fight now if
you guessed that Batman was going to
turn into a tenfold tall vampire bat
that you got me beat it looks like Roz
didn't see that coming either and Batman
does make short work of him turning the
Demon's head into a purple calamari but
think about it if he had some more
corrosive chemicals or explosives with
him maybe Batman could have damaged the
cliff that Roz was standing on causing
him to fall into the pit and taking him
out that way instead and yes he saved
Gotham but now Batman is permanently
mutated into a hideous creature and I'm
not happy with letting our boy go out
with that if I were Kylie I'd use my new
resources to hire a crew and head back
to an article where this whole thing
began then I tried to round up any of
the mutated penguins that still might be
chilling out there and bring them back
to Gotham where I'd have the boys in the
lab study them to hopefully come up with
some sort of serum that turns them back
into their normal cuddly selves and from
there I could reverse the mutation of
the Penguins and then I should be able
to use that same serum on Batman and
save him from being stuck that way
forever it's the very least that I could
do after he saved our reality and it
would also help us better understand
what we were up against if the creature
ever came back several months later
Lucius hosts a memorial in memory of
Oliver and Harvey Kylie steps up to the
microphone and tells the crowd that
she's sure that even in death Bruce is
still watching over them and if they
really need him one day he'll return in
the clock tower high above the Batman
hangs in the darkness having finally
become what he was always meant to be a
giant 10 foot tall bat
foreign